Star Wars: The Last Jedi may be a certified
box office hit in the United States, but it
doesn't hold such a strong distinction overseas.
Although the film has held solidly in European
markets, it failed to take hold in the key
blockbuster market of China, pulling in only
$28.7 million over its second place opening
weekend.
Here's why The Last Jedi struggled in China.
It's just not as popular
A large portion of the United States' adult
population in 2017 grew up with the Star Wars
franchise as a childhood touchstone.
However, in China, the original Star Wars
movies never received a wide theatrical release.
The country's first major introduction to
the franchise came courtesy of the prequel
trilogy.
The new trilogy, however, builds heavily on
the mythology and characters introduced in
the original films, not the prequels.
The chance to finally see Luke Skywalker speak
again was enough to draw millions of fans
across the rest of the world, but those moments
didn't hold the same allure for Chinese audiences.
The marketing fell short
Disney is well aware that Star Wars doesn't
the same box office traction in China, so
they've put in a lot of effort over the years
trying to ramp up recognition.
This kicked off in the months leading up to
the release of 2015's The Force Awakens, when
the company placed 500 stormtroopers on the
Great Wall and hired pop star Lu Han to be
an "official ambassador" for the movie.
For The Last Jedi, Disney tried once again
to drum up the buzz they got for The Force
Awakens.
This included a significant number of billboards
and mobile ads, as well as a premiere at the
Shanghai Disney Resort featuring the film's
biggest stars.
However, ComScore senior media analyst Paul
Dergarabedian believes that it may have been
too little, too late.
"To elevate the brand in China it may be a
matter of consistency more than anything else."
It's worth noting that the standalone Rogue
One: A Star Wars Story also earned a release
in China, bringing in $32.4 million in its
opening weekend—more than The Last Jedi.
That film, however, had the benefit of two
local stars, Donnie Yen and Jiang Wen, who
lured audiences in.
Piracy problems
The Last Jedi hit theaters on December 14
in the United States, but it wasn't released
in China until January 5.
With a film this highly anticipated, piracy
was obviously a concern, and the fact that
the release date was so much later in China
may have encouraged some fans to catch the
film illegally online instead of paying to
see it in theaters.
Although the later release date may have hurt
the film, it was something Disney pushed for.
The company was said to have initially been
offered a release date closer to the U.S.
debut, but they chose to avoid the crowded
early December box office, which left early
January as the best option.
Strong local competition
Although Disney pushed the release date to
try to avoid competition, they still managed
to throw The Last Jedi up against one of China's
strongest franchises: The Ex-Files.
The third film in the romantic comedy series,
The Ex-Files 3: Return of the Exes, was able
to beat out The Last Jedi during its second
week in theaters, pulling in $86.7 million
to The Last Jedi's $28.7 million.
Regardless of why The Last Jedi flopped in
China, there's no need to be concerned about
the film's ultimate box office fate.
It earned the second-highest opening of all
time in North America, behind only The Force
Awakens, and managed to beat out Disney's
wildly popular Beauty and the Beast to become
the highest-grossing film of 2017, despite
only being in theaters for two weeks before
the end of the year.
It also managed to cross $1 billion worldwide,
sitting it at just over $1.2 billion as of
the making of this video—good for the all-time
13th highest-grossing film worldwide.
The Last Jedi may not be doing well in China,
but Disney has nothing to worry about when
it comes to the film's overall performance.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!